it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene Cronus cope Larry lesser from the
CBS television news staff and August
texture chief editorial writer for The
New York Herald Tribune our
distinguished guest for this evening is
the honorable Ernest a gross former
United States ambassador to the United
Nations and assistant secretary of state
for now on until next fall when the
United Nations assembly meets and the
congressional elections take place this
country will be faced by a continuing
question can we keep Red China out of
the United Nations now our guest tonight
has probably had more experience in
fighting the battle of and against Red
China's entry and successfully i may say
than any other man mr. gross we'd like
to ask you as our former ambassador to
the United Nations what do you think are
present chances of keeping China out are
at the moment I feel very confident that
the Communist Chinese government will
not win its seat in the United Nations
either in the General Assembly when it
reconvenes or in the Security Council
and I believe that will be impossible
because the great majority of the
countries in the world I think this
applies to all the Western European
countries to all of Latin America now
with perhaps no exceptions the British
Commonwealth had several countries in
Asia and several countries in the Middle
East will oppose the Chinese Communist
representation in the United Nation but
just too gross for example in 1950
before Korea with hourly comparable
United sentiment against the admission
it was not nearly as strong the in the
Security Council
in 1950 before Korea the Chinese
Communists who came very very close
indeed to winning a seat on the Security
Council there is no doubt that in the
General Assembly there was strong
sentiment in favor of seating the
Chinese Communists mr. gross are we
against the Red Chinese entry in the UN
because he's an aggressor now or because
we hope someday to overthrow her
revolutionary government the problem of
representation of a member state such as
China is a different problem than the
one of admitting a state into membership
in the United Nations it seems like a
technical difference but under the
charter of the United Nations it's a
very important distinction you mean
Tyler is already a member of the US
China is already a member of the United
Nations the question is who is to
represent China now china now has a
representative in a Security Council the
representative is dr. TF Chang o is a
very able and distinguished one of the
leaders of the the free world cause in
the United Nations he remains a
representative V representative of China
until he's replaced and the General
Assembly the delegations of the
nationalist Chinese government have been
very distinguished they would be
replaced by the Communist Chinese if
they won their seat mr. gross when you
were our ambassador to the United
Nations you said that the admission of
Red China to the United Nations or the
ousting of nationalist China was not
subject to the veto but the present
secretary of state mr. Dulles says it is
subject to the veto how do you explain
that in January of nineteen fifty on
instructions from the government I did
announce that the position of the United
States government was that we were
opposed to the admission of Red China to
the Security Council but that we would
accept a majority decision you didn't
say that both at a veto was impossible
you said you didn't want to use the veto
well we we said that we would accept the
decision actually our position was based
upon a very simple and logical point
the fact of the matter is that the
charter of the United Nations provides
the procedural questions and the
Security Council are not subject to the
veto the question of who represents a
member state is or has been regarded as
a procedural question and it's very
simple there's a very simple
common-sense reason why because you see
if a permanent member of the Security
Council one of the so-called big five
had the right to veto in the case of who
represented a government who was on the
Security Council then my good friend dr.
TFT on I hope he stays on the council
for a long long time but doctored seeing
the nationalist Chinese representative
could veto his own replacement because
he represents China China is a permanent
member of the Security Council and
therefore there wouldn't be no chance of
his being replaced that the question of
the United States using its veto would
never arise Chinese videos design you
will probably use it themselves does
this mean mr. gross that if Guatemala's
new government were on the Security
Council that Russia would be to it well
that's an interesting point because if
the guatemauler were a member of the
Security Council and the Communists the
Soviets did not like the new government
they would veto the replacement of the
representative of the former government
of Guatemala so there are very practical
reasons there for a why we should rely
upon the straight majority principle and
not get into the complications which
would be caused by by the application of
the veto which i think is unnecessary in
any event I nevertheless in the assembly
what sort of a vote will be needed there
to keep Red China well excuse me
majority of 31 simple majority or two
shorter they're the United Nations it
provides that the in the General
Assembly votes on important questions
have to be taken by a two-thirds
majority of how society yes what is an
important question well the the
procedure is that the majority of the
members of the assembly I decide whether
or not it is important if the majority
decides it seems there is an important
question that it requires it
thirds vote to carry a proposition I
have no doubt that the problem of the
representation of China would be
regarded by a majority of the members as
a an important question and therefore
would be subject to the 230 isn't all
this discussion rather backwards
wouldn't be first when the vote come up
on the ousting of famosa of the
nationalist Chinese government before
Red China could be seated well what
happens in the General Assembly is that
each time there's a session of the
assembly both rival candidates present
their credentials you say so that the
credentials committee which is appointed
each time the assembly begins its
session once a year it has to pass upon
which contestant which competitor is
entitled to the seat for that government
was rich i'd actually been doing that
every red china has been sending teller
a telegraphic communication they have
not been given visas to appear in person
at the UN headquarters but they have
been sending a cable regularly and
dutifully each time the General Assembly
convenes and claiming the seat would you
actually feel or did you feel during
your representation at the Unites that
it coming as Russia actually wanted Red
China to be a member of the UN well I
felt that while I was in the UN I could
never read the mind of the Kremlin I
believe that they have acted
consistently as if they wanted the Red
Chinese alongside them in the Security
Council and I believe that that's the
case I think it's kind of subtle to look
for reasons like yes them are there are
there conditions which can be laid down
and made clear to the world on which we
would admit a Red China at some future
time is there some kind of behavior to
which it would have to well it's
important to try to define the reasoning
there of course the basic point must be
that we should not support the admission
of red Shauna to the UN and lesson until
we consider it to be on our national
interest to do so now in the future in
the indefinite future if we say that we
shall never under any circumstances
support red China's admission of the UN
we are trying to outguess our own
national interest my own conviction is
that we should not support the admission
of Red China to the United Nations until
and unless we decide that our support of
their admission to the UN is more likely
to induce them to change their course of
conduct and bring them into compliance
with the standards of civilized behavior
doses that the UN is not a reformatory
so letting them into the UN would not
reform them they have to purge
themselves first the UN is not a
reformatory I quite agree I think it's
more like a hospital it's supposed to
reflect the state of the world as mr.
Dulles pointed out in his very excellent
book retina 1950 war or peace and it is
of course a supposed to be by design a
fair reflection of the divisions and
tensions of the world I don't not myself
draw it much of a distinction between
communist China and communist Russia so
far as bad behavior is concerned well do
you think mr Groves that if some sort of
agreement is reached in Indochina as
seems possible from the news we've had
recently that the chances of rich on his
entry into the United Nations will be
better well I think that there will be
more pressure on the part of countries
who some of whom are now of course
teetering on the edge of supporting
Communist China those countries which
have recognized communist China there
are some 14 to 16 I'm not don't recall
the exact number have not died by and
large voted to admit wretch on it to the
UN to seat Red China but it is true that
the closer the Chinese Communists come
in the future if they come to compliance
with the standards of international
behavior there will be pressures to seat
them well actually if this pressure gets
very strong and it appears as the Red
China will become a member headed
nations do you think we should withdraw
what would happen if the United States
actually walked out of it I just don't
believe we will walk out of the United
Nations that would lead to a
fragmentation of not of the United
Nations but of our national policy of
solidifying the free world we cannot
possibly break up the United Nation
without reverting to the age-old balance
of power a principle and practice which
has inevitably led to war we have to do
what has been called developed a
community of power I don't think the
United Nations is really working as well
as it should I think that the Russians
have obstructed it from the beginning
but we must it seems to me persevere in
the effort to solidify the free world
and we can only do it through collective
action thank you very much mr. gross we
appreciate having you here tonight the
opinions expressed on the lawn team
Chronos cope were those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the non gene Chronos go--pause Larry
Nasser and August texture our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
Ernest a gross former United States
ambassador to the United Nations and
assistant secretary of state